funny this movies pretty much shallow
how but inward like if how looked inward
and saw himself as John Stamos or
something in this case its Amy Schumer
so I guess you can make shallow Hal in
modern day just has to be
self-deprecating and then it's fine
[Music]
I feel pretty so I feel pretty stars Amy
Schumer she's struggling to live she's
trying to figure it out she wishes she
was more beautiful in one day she bumps
her head and then she sees herself how
she's always wanted to look it never
shows what she sees she just always see
Amy Schumer the entire time but she was
like oh my gosh I'm so beautiful I look
completely different then passes and
life starts opening up to her what I
like about this movie is first of all as
Amy Schumer I know it's kind of a cool
thing to hate Amy Schumer right now I
honestly I haven't seen any of her stand
up everything I know about Amy Schumer I
know from what I've seen in movies I
thought Amy Schumer was really good in
this movie she's fun she's charming I
like the romance she built I like the
romance in this movie because it wasn't
set up on jokes they had jokey banter in
here but in the end it's just it was
such an organic relationship I laughed
and joked like couples laugh and joke I
also like the message in this movie
about being comfortable with yourself
and how you view yourself actually will
affect your world more than how other
people view you it seems a lot of people
are really concerned with what other
people say to or about other people
disregarding the fact that if that goes
away the worlds won't be any different
it'll still be just as miserable or just
as happy as they are people being happy
with themselves that's where happiness
comes from but enough early on when this
trailer came out a lot of people are
saying this movie's problematic or some
[ __ ] I just don't see it at all I don't
see how a movie that says hey
empowerment coming from within it's what
matters I don't see how that message is
somehow toxic but again I don't get
Twitter most of the time anyway so
whatever I did find it weird that I
wasn't laughing a lot in the movie it
didn't even dawn on me until about
halfway through I think it was that way
through this movie feels pretty [ __ ]
long so it might have been halfway
through just at a point I'm watching Amy
Schumer and her on-screen boyfriend I
was like this is very sweet did I
realize I'm not laughing oh my god I
really haven't laughed a lot been this
movie at all I found that kind of weird
for it being their comedy like they were
going for the Judd Apatow route no it's
like it's a comedy but we're gonna
elevate it with a lot of heart and like
every Judd Apatow film or someone who
tries to emulate the Jed Apatow feeling
this movie does feel [ __ ] long too
long way too long so movie feels 2 and a
half hours long it's probably just a
little over two hours maybe around two
hours but if a movie is two hours long
but feels like two and a half hours long
I'd rather a movie be two and a half
hours long that feels 2 hours long that
movie at least we'll have good pacing
movie didn't really have good pace
pacing was sluggish at times at a point
my you can wrap this up any time we get
it we get the point we get the message
we get the feels we can go live
shirt for a movie to be too long in fact
I would argue if this movie had better
pacing I wouldn't have noticed I wasn't
laughing a lot I would have enjoyed the
movie as more heartfelt film rather than
a comedy every think of funniest movies
I've seen lately I'm not gonna think of
this one but heartfelt maybe because in
the end this movie was sweet and
heartfelt not as funny as it wanted to
be the pace was off it was alright I'm
more or less enjoy the message that this
girl's entire world starts to change
things start coming to her but the only
catalyst that actually changed in her
life to get this stuff going is how she
viewed herself I find to be a very real
message very relevant message I like
that in the end this movie had enjoyment
probably would have hit it out of the
park if I had a glass of sangria yeah
now it's a party alright so I feel
pretty have you seen it what did you
think about it or what's a comedy that's
more heartfelt than comedy that you
enjoy whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]